all right winter water restrictions are
back in action across the valley i spoke
with the southern nevada water authority
to help you avoid getting fined it's
time to
tell the community about their winter
water restrictions with
the southern nevada water authority
right absolutely so it's that time of
year where you need to go out and change
your watering clock if you haven't done
that yet
get off the couch go out into your
garage or outside and change that
watering clock
during the winter months you're only
supposed to be watering one day a week
and it's not only a good idea to do it
it is actually the law so make sure you
get out there and do that from now
until february one day a week
it's also um a way that you can save
money too
by changing your watering clock four
times a year
you can save up to 300 on your bill so
who doesn't want to save money right now
right
you can get a water waste fine for over
watering you can get a water waste fine
for watering on the wrong day
and you can get a water waste fine for
watering too many days so if you're not
sure what day you're supposed to water
simply go to snwa.com put in your
address
and your day will pop up and you go out
you make sure you comply
because those waterways finds can be
pretty expensive they they started about
eighty dollars
and double thereafter so nobody wants to
get a water waste fine
no we don't the other things you can do
too is you want to make sure you're
going out and checking your landscape
probably about once a month to make sure
that
you're you don't have any broken
sprinklers that you don't have any
broken irrigation lines so
again that will save you some money and
save water
as well and you're only supposed to be
watering about 12 minutes a day that's
all it takes especially during these
cool
winter months 12 minutes a day is it and
you don't want to do it all at once
because you could get some runoff and
again you don't want to get that water
waste find and as you can tell i have
brought my
my guy ryan reads here he is our water
waste enforcer he's the one that tells
everybody in the community you've
probably seen them all around town
reminding people to change their
watering clocks he is the enforcer so if
you don't change your watering clock
you may show up at your house oh well
don't say that because we're gonna
purposely not chase the water and clock
right but between you
and ryan reeves i think we get it and i
think we are listening for sure
my next question is how else can people
save water i know there are other ways
that you guys
that you guys give the community so one
of the other ways that you can save
water
is by getting rid of grass that you
don't use so if you're only on your
grass when you mow it or to maintain it
take it out we'll pay you three dollars
a square foot to upgrade to water smart
landscaping and there's some beautiful
water smart landscapes out there it's
not just rock and cactus
some beautiful plants that are water
efficient so
that is a great way to experience water
savings
and money savings on your water bill by
getting rid of that grass that you don't
use that's a great thing that you can do
for
for yourself as well as the community
simple rules to follow right there for
more information call 702-258-s-a-v-e
for save or visit snwa.com
we'll be right back here on las vegas
now